hola en este vídeo veremos cómo
encontrar y asignar ejercicios vídeos y
artículos para tus clases o para
estudiantes específicos en el panel de
profesor selecciona una de tus clases
luego haz clic en el botón asignar en el
menú vertical ahora selecciona el curso
que deseas y la plataforma mostrará el
contenido dividido en unidades
las unidades están organizadas en
lecciones que contienen vídeos artículos
y ejercicios
por ejemplo la lección introducción a la
multiplicación tiene tres vídeos un
artículo y cuatro ejercicios de práctica
al hacer clic en el enlace tuvo un
profesor podrás visualizar los
ejercicios ver un vídeo leer un artículo
antes de asignarlos a tus alumnos cuando
encuentres el contenido que necesitas
marca la casilla por actividad
individual o toda la lección luego haz
clic en asignar cada vez que asigne es
una actividad deberás elegir las clases
los alumnos y la fecha el límite de la
asignación
puedes enviar la actividad a una clase
específica y también a todas las clases
a la vez e incluso puedes asignar
actividades para estudiantes específicos
haz clic en asignar para enviar la
actividad inmediatamente o en guardar y
asignar más tarde también puedes definir
si los estudiantes recibirán las mismas
preguntas en el mismo orden
o un conjunto de preguntas seleccionadas
al azar
en el caso de la modalidad de práctica
guiada la opción más interesante es
pedir a los alumnos que trabajen en el
mismo conjunto de preguntas y establecer
una fecha el límite para entregarla en
el caso de prácticas independientes o
tareas es mejor pedir a los estudiantes
que trabajen en diferentes preguntas
otra forma de asignar tareas es a través
del apartado dominios de curso
ahí encontrarás el avance para
visualizar el progreso de tus
estudiantes y por lo tanto es un gran
aliado para asignar actividades que
satisfagan las necesidades de cada uno
de ellos haz clic en una unidad y navega
por las habilidades la plataforma
indicará los niveles de dominio de cada
alumno sugerimos que los estudiantes del
nivel intento tengan más oportunidades
para practicar y dominar esa habilidad
para asignar una actividad sobre la
habilidad seleccionada haga clic en el
botón asignar y realice los ajustes como
se muestra arriba
otra forma de asignar tareas es a través
de la barra de herramientas al navegar
por la página de cada curso puedes
explorar todas las unidades y lecciones
y encontrar el contenido que necesitas
haz click en cualquier video artículo o
ejercicio y la barra de herramientas
aparecerá en la parte superior de la
página también puedes encontrar el
contenido que necesitas utilizando el
buscador ingresa las palabras clave o el
nombre del concepto o tema de tu interés
una vez que aparezcan los resultados de
la búsqueda
podrás filtrar los por vídeos artículos
ejercicios y más cuando encuentres el
contenido que necesitas haz clic en la
actividad y utiliza la barra de
herramientas para completar la
asignación
[Música]
en la página de inicio y en la pestaña
tareas los clientes verán las
actividades que les ha asignado y la
fecha el límite para completar cada
actividad las tareas están ordenadas por
fecha de finalización a medida que los
alumnos completan sus tareas y resuelven
cada pregunta reciben comentarios
instantáneos sobre su desempeño tú
también recibirás la información de
manera inmediata
los estudiantes pueden hacer varios
intentos para completar las asignaciones
a medida que aprenden de sus propios
errores si has asignado diferentes
ejercicios para cada estudiante
recibirán un nuevo conjunto de problemas
seleccionados al azar con cada intento
[Aplausos]
finalmente algunos consejos que nos han
dado profesores que utilizan la
plataforma número uno algunos conceptos
funcionan particularmente bien para la
práctica en el aula elige conceptos que
sean más retadores o que puedan conducir
a buenas discusiones y debates número 2
comienza lentamente asignando pocas
actividades para hacer una clase
gradualmente irás consolidando una
rutina para el uso y ken academy y
conocerás el ritmo de sus estudiantes
para obtener más información sobre can
academic visita nuestro centro de ayuda
y consulta nuestra sección de preguntas
frecuentes